Gareth would love to hear how you
construct an action scene or sequence
are you storyboarding it are you
planning it out blow-by-blow is it
spontaneous in some sense I'm I'm like a
terrible artist I can't draw at all so I
tend to avoid storyboards you know he's
laughing already
but what we do is because it's really a
hard actually to capture like the
martial arts movement with like a still
image so what we tend to always do is we
make like a video storyboard so we'll
work on the car or if you designed
together first and then once we've
settled on what the actual scene is
going to be and the structure of it then
after that then we all kind of like go
through the kahan DCAM just in the
office with a couple of crash mats and
videotape this whole process and we
start to figure out what shot were angle
what edit is gonna be best serving to
that piece of choreography so we never
really do anything where it's like I
soaked a wide shot master and then get
coverage this this and this and try to
figure out in the Edit it's all kind of
predetermined
and that's all in that pre-production
stage of it so we end up having at the
end of it like this sort of guide video
that we can use and the tells all the
different departments you know okay in
this shot it's this piece of
choreography and this shot you need to
have this makeup prepared ready for this
guy and it's a good good way to
communicate everything and everyone
understands I'm the full fluidity of the
shot and the Edit
you